PROFESSOR: OK.
Finally, I'm going to solve this
first order linear differential
equation with a formula that
works for any source term.
So we've solved it for specific,
nice, special source terms
I'll remember later.
But now we want a
formula for the solution
to that equation, period.
And we want to
understand the formula.
So now, write the
formula down, and then
let's see why it's right.
And then of course, we could
put it into the equation
and confirm that it's right.
OK the formula is
going to be-- this
is the big formula you
could say, for first order
linear equations.
So y of t.
First we have the result
of the amount-- I'm
thinking of this as balance.
The money in the bank is why
it's increasing at this rate,
because of interest being added.
And it's increasing at this
rate because of new deposits
being added.
And oh, maybe I should
say about those deposits,
I'm not thinking of like deposit
once a year, or once a month,
or once a minute, even.
Deposit continuously.
We're talking differential
equations here.
Time is running all-- the
clock is always running.
So you're--
theoretically, at least--
you're depositing at a
rate of so much per second,
all the time.
OK.
So first, the y of 0,
that's a once in a lifetime
deposit to start the account.
And it grows, as we know,
with the interest rate
as the exponent.
The question is-- so that's
the null solution that
matches the initial condition.
No solution, because there
are no deposits here.
This solves this part of
the equation, the null part.
But now I want to add in
a particular solution,
and it'll be the
particular solution
that matches the deposits.
And I want to
understand this formula.
So here's the formula.
I'm going to-- the deposits
each deposit goes in at time T,
goes in at some time,
and then it grows.
Once you've made
the deposit, it's
going to grow exponentially.
With [INAUDIBLE], it will
grow over the remaining time.
So here's the formula.
You make deposits at any time,
s, between s equal 0 and s
equal t.
So s is the running clock.
T is the-- we look at our
account and see what's in it.
And this deposit
is made at time s,
and then it grows over the
remaining time, from s to t.
So it grows by a factor
e to the a, t minus s.
That's the key.
And now we add up all those
deposits with their growth.
So that addition for continuous
time addition is integration.
That's the whole
idea of the integral,
is add up continuously.
So there's my formula that
I'm hoping you will admire.
The no solution that grows
out of the initial condition.
The particular solution that
grows out of the source term,
q.
Of course I've used
q of t all the way.
Here I call it q of s.
I have to introduce a
integration variable
s, which goes from the
start of these deposits
until the current time,
and grows like that.
So that's the formula.
I could put a big box around it.
Let me start a box anyway.
I could check that it's correct.
But I hope you see
why it's right.
And let me make some
comment on the examples of q
where we didn't
have this formula.
We just went for it directly.
So we started with,
these were special.
Especially nice, you could say.
Q of t equal a constant.
That was the first video.
Then we did q of t
equal an exponential.
That was the second one.
Then we did-- so and then we
found the exponential response.
Then I did oscillation.
Cosine-- well, let me put it
over here-- cosine of omega t.
Or plus sine of omega t.
You remember, those two kind
of had to come together.
We couldn't stick
with cosines alone,
because the
derivative of a cosine
here would give us a sign, so
signs got into the picture.
So we found the
formula for that,
that took a little more work.
And in fact we did it by a real
method and a complex method.
And, now are there any other
nice functions in calculus?
Well the next video,
I'm going to tell you
about two more functions
that I think are very nice.
Step function.
So the deposit-- we don't
make any deposits up
until some time,
and then we start,
then we go change to constant.
So the step function is
0 and then a constant.
And also-- and this is the
especially interesting one--
a delta function.
And what is a delta function?
Which doesn't always come
into the basic differential
equations, course,
but it belongs there.
Because in a model of
reality, a delta function
is like a golf club
hitting a golf ball.
In an instant
something happened.
Or a baseball bat
hitting a baseball.
It gives it an instant velocity.
It's an impulse.
So step function is like a
light switch off and then on.
Delta function is all in
one instant, an impulse,
and you'll see that coming.
And then those are
the-- oh, and maybe I
could include-- let's see,
if I've got a constant,
maybe should include
t, t squared, so on.
Powers of t are not too bad.
We could get--
So for all of these special ones
that I call the nice functions.
For all of those-- and we could
multiply t times e to the st,
that would still be nice.
And we could have
a simple formula.
Those are the ones that give
simple, direct, interesting,
answers in themselves.
And this is the one that
gives the general answer.
And if I put q be any one of
those in this general formula,
I'll get the special one.
You can see how if I
put a constant in there,
that will be exactly
what we found
at the very, very beginning
for the response to a constant.
Right.
So this is the
general expression.
I feel I should
say more about it.
I guess I should say, two
more things I want to add
about this general formula.
One is, I should check
that it's correct.
But I hope you saw,
it had to be right.
This input went in, it
grew, everything was linear.
So I could just add the separate
growth, separate results,
to find out what the balance
was at the final time, t.
But still, I can check it.
And I can derive it.
That step is always
often done by what's
called an integrating factor.
So there will be
a quick video that
shows you how an integrating
factor leads to that formula.
Right in this video,
I'm just saying I
was led to it by common sense.
But I can check
that it's correct.
So let me check
OK.
This part I can see is correct.
So I'd like to
work with that one
and show that that is
a particular solution
to the differential equation.
Can I do that?
I want to show that
this-- I'm looking now
at this y particular, and I'll
factor out the e to the at,
because it doesn't depend on s.
It's not involved
in the integration.
So this is in the integral from
s equals 0 to s equal t of e
to the minus as,
that has an s in it.
Q of s, ds.
This is all the stuff
that depends on what time
the deposit was made, time s.
And what time we're looking at
the balance, the later time, t.
OK.
This is a product of one
term times another term.
And when I put it into
the differential equation,
I'll use the product rule.
So the derivative
of that product
will have two terms
from the product rule.
And those two terms
will be-- if all
goes well-- will be the two
terms in the differential
equation.
So can I take the derivative
of this by the product rule?
So I take the derivative
of the first thing,
so now I'm computing dy,
dt, by ordinary calculus.
So the derivative of that is a
e the at times the second term.
That's just ay.
That's a times the y
that we had before.
Because the derivative of e
to the at, by the chain rule,
brings down an a,
and we have that.
But now the product
rule says also I
must take that term times
the derivative of this term.
And that looks messier.
What's the derivative
of that function?
It's a function of t.
But it's an integral.
What's it's time derivative?
That's the last piece
of the product rule.
Well, look what it is.
It's the integral up to
time t of some function.
And the fundamental
theorem of calculus
says that the derivative
of the integral
is the original function, right?
So the derivative
of this integral
is the original function
that we integrated at time t.
So it's e to the
minus a t cubed t.
That's the second term
from the product rule.
And OK, this was
the ay, perfectly.
And what do I have here?
E to the at cancels
e to the minus at,
and it's the source term q of t.
So I have ay plus q of t,
the correct right hand side
for the differential equation.
So this, that formula, let
me bring it down once more,
is sort of the climax of
this beginning of the videos
to see first order linear
differential equations.
So what's coming now are
step and delta function.
I just want to
speak about those.
And that takes a few
minutes separately.
And then another step will
be to allow the interest
rate to change.
We made our problem
simple because we've
kept a constant interest rate.
So I'll let the
interest rate change.
And then after that
comes the real step
to non-linear equations.
So delta functions,
varying interest rate,
and then non-linear equations.
And then on to second
order equations
and all the rest of the theory
of differential equations.
Good.
Thank you.